bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj oggi
siamo di nuovo sul saggio il simulator
raga forse dico forse non sono sicuro
siamo alla perché cazzo dovete già
chiamarvi non ha neanche cominciato dai
riesco oggi ne faccio non un'operazione
ma due
e allora prima i ragazzi ci mancavano
nell'operazione in ambulanza
il trapianto di reni e poi quello di
cervello a rega prima di tutto vorrei
farvi notare una cosa ma quale dottore
meglio di mentre in una sala operatoria
con questa maglietta ragazzi giovani
iniziare come si deve allora c'è certo
non è un po dio sta accadendo più
perfetto iniziare come si deve e quando
mai detto questa cosa non me lo ricordo
e vabbè allora prendiamo il martello
vediamo di riuscire a fare le cose più
in fretta possibile prima che questo
mischianti ed evo piano va al dragao dio
cos'è cosa cazzo forza ragazzi
paranormal martello ed è voci no marte
ma cazzo vabbè non voglio fare domani
oddio no che mi ammazzo il paziente
pietro grasso raja non c'è allora stiamo
iniziando malissimo
vediamo di staccate vediamo di riuscire
a non ammazzarlo prima del tempo alla
ragazza possiamo fare è un'impresa
titanica ma già possiamo fare stai fermo
si j che qui dall'ambulanza devo
riuscire a staccare i vari ok perfetto
ci siamo ce la posso fare laga
incredibile non ci posso credere
ce l'ho fatta costa caro anche questo
staccarne mixer ok piano fermati fermati
che mi muore il paziente fermo dove la
siringa gioverà seguitemi
no non c'è eccola qua e qua fermo
toglietevi tutti dalle brutto stronzo
togli che devo prenderla vai vai vai vai
se ce la faccio mai
vai così niente li del gelato lamentava
così sì perché questa roba spiegatemi
che cosa secondo me è e menta o sono
calcoli sciolte non voglio neanche
saperlo via allora ci siamo st 3 mila e
ho tagliato quasi tutti i prezzi non ci
posso credere ma lui non si è accorto di
nuovo cos'è controllato ho trovato una
forbice ho trovato di e tua per caso
tieni non mi serve mi6 incastrata ma
cosa devo buttare via tutto via lostan
ago via mangiatelo che regga che cosa
succede se si mangia lo stomaco doveva
finire ma perché mi faccio questa
domanda è allora b anche questo non si
sa che cos'è sta roba usata per
impiccarti non lo so è anche questo
cos'è sta roba perché già un cucciolo di
alieno all'interno del paziente
dormi c insieme fa qualcosa usano come
cuscino ma io qua devo operare non ci
posso ce la sto per fare non ci credo
vai col taglio dei reni ce la posso fare
sarebbe sale ragazzi un traguardo
assurda al primo tentativo non è mai
riuscito niente e ce la faccio cosa per
azione più difficili in ambulanti ma
starò battaglia avrei trovato alle
piccolo chimico no taglia taglia
mentre un rene andato anche l'altro se
vai
allora ragazzi siamo dobbiamo
sostituirli e quanto st ce la possiamo
fare la gamma sta perdendo sangue non ci
voglio credere
al primo tentativo sarebbe un traguardo
assurdo primaria che ce lo mettiamo
prima che vada vada giù dall'ambulanza
allora vai lì dice la ragazza altre rene
o soltanto togliere store n se ce la
posso fare via dal gatto guardone cazzo
si è ficcato l'altro rene ma può andare
così indietro maledizione come lo
raggiungo il devo tagliare un braccio
per raggiungerlo dai che ce la faccio
prendilo mi sembra di giocare con le
robe delle sale giochi dove devi
prendere i cosi vabbè ci siamo allora
mancate no stai fermo lì non fare bungee
jumping non è ora e allora devo riuscire
a mettere l'altro venne da che ci riesco
dai che ci riesco ce l'ho fatta non ci
posso credere
raga primo tentativo non è mai successo
che io ci sia riuscita la prima volta ed
è successo con l'operazione più
difficile in ambulanza non ci credo
ovviamente ancora devo fare quella nello
spazio e quindi non so qual è il livello
di difficoltà massimo ma non importa
ci sono riuscito ragazze di fare
l'operazione al cervello così al
prossimo episodio
raga annunciato ci sarà quella nello
spazio è veramente vi giuro non vedo
l'ora che ce la possiamo fare baia
operazione al cervello e la prima volta
che mi riesce a primo colpo veramente
cioè non ci posso credere anche ai
ragazzi siamo siamo arrivati
all'operazione fantastica per la il
cervello
vediamo se riesco a fare una bellissima
figura come l'ultima volta
allora prendiamo di anzitutto il da
merck che no perché mi credono giovane
non importa e ora di operare vediamo di
riuscire a prendere la mira come si deve
vai vai che ha tolto addio
cosa è successo no perfetto da non era
esattamente cia un'ascia
se frena l'ambulanza sono cattivi mi sa
che devo passare al trapianto di cuore
se ferrante 6 frena di colpo l'ambulanza
va bene ce la posso fare la gara
credette in me credenti ma che non sto
riuscendo
ok perfetto lo smaterializzato direi che
ci siamo vai con la siringa dove ce ne
sono due
ma letizia allora io le prendo tutto il
giorno perfetto per stata quella
sbagliata
oddio no sto perdiamo addio santissimo
d'altro siringa veloce veloce veloce
veloce no ce lo chapiteau addio santi
cos'era quella roba adrenalina c'era
caso riuscita fanno morire
nell'operazione al cervello e non in
quella coi reni che è impossibile ma
anche come è potuto accadere sta cosa
via alla ragazzi mi set dove la siringa
questa volta lo prendo giusta era il
succo di calcolo è quella giusta non
l'altra fi nell'orecchio occhio o mio
dio ce lo impianta io tralasciati di
volentieri o che perfetto era ciclo
continuo così devo sollevare il cervello
del paziente
ok giro braga paranormal al cervello a
qualcuno di voi mi deve dare una
spiegazione scientifica a tutto questo a
mio zio santissimo ragazza è qualcosa di
epico mi guardate che oggi a cosa
mio dio raga non ci penso ma l'esorcista
ci fa una pippa questo qui ma cos'è la
gama l'esorcista ci fa una pippa questo
qui o mio dio
guardate che roba è raga io non ci sto
trovando una spiegazione logica
tra un po di parte la testa io direi di
iniziare prima che degeneri la
situazione raga veramente stato
incredibile questo qui si va a finire
nel prossimo montaggio ma sicuro ragazzi
dovremmo essere
mi manca la sinistra stringa perfetto e
qua possiamo fare vari posti togliti
tazza di merda può già fatto colazione e
non certo aiuti ma che cazzo allora
senta trovi mette la tazza di sistemare
qualcosa vuole un tè non lo sa si serva
lei devo riuscire a prendere la siringa
prima che il paziente mischiatti no ma
letizia mi sono drogato allora fermo per
o che ci siamo dove devo ritrovarmi di
nuovo perché se no non vedo una mazza
allora devo toccare la siringa prendi la
setta loro intenzioni cattive stai calmo
ok perfetto ai fermo oggi ai ragazzi
tagliamolo prima che diventi indemoniato
un'altra volta vi serve il bisturi
ok ce la possiamo fermo fermo per ok
ragazzi sta morendo piano pianissimo
devo tagliare ce l'ha fatta ce la posso
fare vai o mio dio
dai dai dai dai dai set rega due
operazioni in un video anche se si cela
mani è saltato cervello tanto è il mio
compito l'ho fatto saranno cazzi di un
altro dottore adesso non mi importa
ragazzi abbiamo finito tutti i livelli
tutti i livelli di sergio simulator
abbiamo fatto ricapitolando il trapianto
di cuore di reni e di cervello sia in
sala operatoria c'è in ambulanza e li
abbiamo finiti tutti con tanto di
possessione demoniaca da parte del
paziente allora ragazzi ma anche
all'ultima operazione che farò nel
prossimo video del quale vi faccio
soltanto vedere
l'ambientazione anche perché voglio
vedere ma io sto morendo e dal primo
episodio che voglio farla e non la
faccio adesso ma voglio soltanto vedere
di che si tratta sarà fantastico e
inseriamo sta roba da la prima se ci
riesco dai che l'abbiamo visto le tue
performance
abbiamo bisogno del tuo servizio per una
missione speciale inserendo questo disco
e ha consentito di aiutarci e un agente
verrà prenderti immediatamente praga o
mio dio
cos'è welcome to space nine è il
benvenuto nello spazio radio fantastica
guardate che no veramente lega questa è
la cosa più epica che io abbia mai visto
sarà impossibile fare un'operazione qui
vieni ragala faro nel prossimo episodio
di sicuro a gravità zero operare sarà un
disastro
vabbè raga io per questo episodio la
chiudo qui non è solito ragazze video è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione
sempre sindaco risi discrete vene ci
vediamo prossimo video per ragazzi
[Musica]